hello camera i'm jason mewes and i'm
here playing around with some cool stuff
i feel like this is a lightsaber almost
poo poo pee poo poo poo pee poop that's
what I feel like this room oh wait a sec
oh can I didn't realize till now the
controller's clothes and a little wiener
pops out sorry I probably can't say that
here got your multi tools at the
charging station locate and open the
correct whoa whoa that is great give me
some chocolate cake mm-hmm chocolate
cake whoa there's desk oh my God look
there there I am at my desk my cubicle
and his little dude jump with running
around screaming oh whoa whoa and it's
break in here like things are falling
over chairs are moving something there
we go i opened it oh whoa I see the
robot in there dude there's a dude
reading and there's a dude here that is
really trippy know that is crazy wow
dude he's coming right Timmy oh man this
is really trippy all look please plate
open I can open the fit yo I'm opening
there dude I'm opening up his face oh
yeah look you can read the nav module
Atlas multi-core yellow module so here
if I slide this up slide this up
oh here I got a hit slide oh no looks
like a robot can't handle the tempest
whoa it's you congratulations on your
quota filling promotion by the way
you've opened our eyes to what humans
can achieve when you put your tiny
little minds to it Luther King it was
like oh yeah that's funky everyone don't
do drugs you just got this all right
gamespot thank you for letting me come
here play with the awesomeness which was
portal oculus is some things of what not
I got the paint I got to look at the
portal and travel through time if you
will but honestly was fun amazing place
thank you very much check out jay and
silent bob chronic blunt punch a video
game that will be out in hopefully 18
months or less but we're doing a little
crowdsourcing at fig f IG dot CEO